cosa rende simili un forno a microonde e
un sistema di intelligenza artificiale
Vi chiedo un attimo di pazienza so che
siete stanchi ma tra poco lo capiremo
perché stasera vorrei parlarvi di
tecnologia e intelligenza artificiale
per riflettere insieme a voi sulle idee
e i valori con cui le
progettiamo durante l'epoca delle
rivoluzioni industriali era molto
diffusa una teoria in base a cui si
pensava fosse lo sviluppo tecnologico a
causare qualsiasi cambiamento Progresso
nella
società Questa teoria è diventata poi
nota con il nome di determinismo
tecnologico proprio per l'idea che sia
la tecnologia a determinare il nostro
futuro A partire dagli anni 70 alcuni
filosofi e sociologi hanno iniziato a
mettere in discussione questa teoria
sostenendo che un rapporto di causa
effetto non fosse sufficiente per
spiegare il rapporto tra tecnologia e
società ma servisse piuttosto
un
intreccio in base a questa seconda
interpretazione dietro e all'interno
della progettazione di ogni tecnologia
esistono precise ragioni sociali
politiche culturali economiche a
renderla possibile e a
influenzarla perché vi sto dicendo tutto
questo Pippone
storico perché sto notando ultimamente
negli ultimi mesi molte argomentazioni
deterministe intorno al dibattito
sull'intelligenza artificiale penso
Soprattutto quella generativa dii
sicuramente mte e molti tra voi hanno
sentito
parlare dalla Silicon Valley ci sono
arrivate alcun affermazioni come
l'intelligenza Arale ha una
Cosenza opp È un rischio esistenziale
per la civiltà umana al pari di pandemie
e guerre nucleari
Ma c'è effettivamente Qualcosa di vero
dietro questa narrazione così
predominante in questo
momento Beh non hanno proprio tutti i
torti c'è sicuramente qualcosa di
potenzialmente problematico legato ad
alcuni degli utilizzi che stiamo facendo
dell'intelligenza artificiale solo che
stasera insieme a voi preferisco parlare
di impatti reali piuttosto che di rischi
esistenziali Perché i rischi almeno per
come li stiamo vedendo ora ci appaiono
come qualcosa di distante futuro e
soprattutto fuori dal nostro controllo
ma è davvero così l'intelligenza
artificiale è una tecnologia E come ogni
tecnologia è una creazione umana Questo
significa che le sue qualità le
decidiamo noi vi faccio un esempio breve
perché così iniziamo a capire cosa
significa controllare e influenzare una
tecnologia nel 1993 due sociologo
femministe hanno condotto uno studio
empirico sul forno a
microonde svelando Tra le altre cose che
il rapporto tra generi e i ruoli di
genere avevano profondamente influenzato
il suo
design noi pensiamo alla progettazione
degli oggetti delle tecnologie come
qualcosa di scontato in realtà succede
di tutto Ci sono scelte negoziazioni
compromessi
litigi e
infatti grazie a questo studio sappiamo
che il forno a microonde era stato
inizialmente progettato come un
accessorio high-tech destinato agli
uomini e veniva venduto di fianco a
televisioni e
stereo Poi però è successo qualcosa gli
uomini non ne volevano sapere Non lo
compravano e quindi si è dovuto
ripensare riprogettare riconfigurare il
forno a microonde per dei nuovi utilizzi
ed è lì che è nato quello che conosciamo
destinato alle donne
casalinghe diventato bianco e che ancora
oggi viene venduto nei reparti al fianco
di frigoriferi e
lavastoviglie Io penso che questo
esempio sia
molto
calzante per farci capire quando Quante
scelte e quante intenzioni ci sono
quando viene progettata una
tecnologia ora torniamo agli impatti
reali Cioè cosa sta succedendo di
effettivamente problematico legato
all'utilizzo dell'intelligenza
artificiale per capirlo dobbiamo per un
secondo soffermarci su come funzionano
queste tecnologie tendenzialmente
vengono allenate su grosse quantità di
dati informazioni che possiamo pensare
come ad esempio il genere l'età la
situazione
economica il numero di proprietà o di
figli che una persona
possiede tutti questi dati vengono poi
fatti elaborare da dei modelli
matematici che a loro volta sono
costituiti da
algoritmi regole istruzioni che dicono
al modello come deve elaborare quei
dati una volta che il modello li ha
elaborati e interpretati produce Un
output un risultato che può essere una
risposta come binaria ad esempio come
affidabile o non
affidabile in base a questa
logica i sistemi di intelligenza
artificiale tendono a mantenere lo
status quo perché generalizzano in base
ad ampie categorie come quelle che vi ho
detto per questo motivo uno degi impatti
reali più problematici dell'intelligenza
artificiale quello di riprodurre le
discriminazioni
sociali Ad esempio nei confronti di
donne giovani persone nere persone
povere o la comunità lgbtq insomma
qualsiasi
discriminazione che esista già nella
nostra
società spostiamoci su due esempi molto
concreti e molto vicini a ciò di cui mi
occupo nello specifico le decisioni
automatizzate usate da agenzie e
amministrazioni
pubbliche Sara è una madre olandese si è
recentemente separata dal marito e ora
ha in custodia i suoi due figli per
questo motivo per occuparsi di loro ha
dovuto lasciare il lavoro e ora si
affida a dei programmi di welfare
pubblico in Olanda in base a queste
caratteristiche che vedete evidenziate
in rosa il fatto di essere una donna il
fatto di essere una madre single con due
figli a carico e il fatto di non avere
più un lavoro Sara è stata giudicata
come ad alto rischio di commettere una
frode sui sussidi allo stato da parte di
un software di intelligenza artificiale
usato dal governo olandese questo ha
avuto degli enormi impatti sulla sua
vita sia privata sia pubblica A partire
dal fatto che le è stato chiesto di
restituire tutti i sussidi che aveva
ricevuto fino a quel momento e le è
stato bloccato qualsiasi nuovo sussidio
ma anche una sorveglianza settimanale da
parte delle autorità che hanno causato a
loro volta uno stigma
sociale quello che è successo a Sara è
successo ad altre 25.000 famiglie nei
Paesi Bassi che sono state
ingiustamente di frode
e questo scandalo è
stato definito come il più grande
esempio di discriminazione di massa
basata sui dati a danno di cittadini da
parte di un governo europeo o ancora da
parte dello stesso Parlamento olandese
come un'ingiustizia senza
precedenti Andiamo su un altro esempio
Omar un ragazzo un adolescente di 16
anni con origini siriane la sua famiglia
si è trasferita nei Paesi Bassi
chiedendo asilo politico è stata
assegnata a tre diverse programmi di
accoglienza ha cambiato tre città e
quindi Omar ha dovuto cambiare tre
scuole un giorno ha anche assistito
all'arresto di suo padre accusato di
violenza domestica ai danni della madre
per queste caratteristiche sempre che
vedete evidenziate Omar è stato
giudicato da parte di un software di
polizia predittiva sempre usato dal
governo olandese come un adolescente con
un alto rischio di diventare un
criminale nel
futuro nella situazione di Omar c'erano
altri 400 adolescenti nella città di
Amsterdam
dove un oracolo un algoritmo che ha
preso le sembianze di un oracolo ha
deciso per il loro futuro perché le
persone le istituzioni si sono fidate di
quel risultato e hanno iniziato a
trattare questi adolescenti già come dei
criminali
Ora non so se notate qualcosa in comune
a questi esempi sono solo due
impatti reali dell'intelligenza
artificiale oggi e sono sicura che c'è
qualcuno tra di voi che sta pensando Beh
ma non c'è niente di così strano un
funzionario pubblico potrebbe aver preso
la stessa
decisione è
vero la differenza però sta nel fatto
che quando un pregiudizio umano viene
scolpito nel codice quel pregiudizio non
avviene più una
ma 25.000 volte o 400 volte nello stesso
istante quando vi parlavo di
amplificazione delle discriminazioni
intendevo proprio
questo quello che io vedo in comune a
questi due esempi è il fatto che dietro
a queste tecnologie c'erano degli esseri
umani con le loro
scelte il fatto di chiedere a un
software di prevedere il rischio di
criminalità negli adolescenti è una
scelta umana usare il genere come
indicatore di rischio per la frode è una
scelta umana e decidere Quanto peso dare
alla variabile nazionalità è una scelta
umana queste non sono scelte che fa il
computer sono scelte che facciamo
noi torniamo al
microonde Quali sono i valori con cui
oggi progettiamo l'intelligenza
artificiale che intenzioni abbiamo
quando chiediamo alla tecnologia di
automatizzare un processo e davvero Il
futuro che vogliamo è quello in cui dei
software prevedono il nostro rischio di
diventare dei
criminali Secondo me troppo spesso
dimentichiamo di porci queste
domande ci comportiamo come se TR
tecnologia ci dall'alto ma non è
così non c'è niente di magico in queste
tecnologie non ci accadono
semplicemente E quello che vorrei
trasmettervi
stasera è che nessuna macchina ancora
agisce
autonomamente c'è sempre almeno un input
iniziale umano ed è su questo che
dobbiamo focalizzarci perché siamo noi
che progettiamo queste tecnologie ancora
prima di essere noi ad utilizzarle e
decidere cosa far fare a
loro e questo è molto
importante perché quando invece
attribuiamo poteri umani alla tecnologia
stiamo
metterla sul mercato e che invece hanno
tutta la
responsabilità di progettare delle
tecnologie non
discriminatorie è questa Secondo me la
vera
sfida educare le persone la
società a non avere paura di questi
software di queste
tecnologie
Perché l'unica cosa su cui dobbiamo
focalizzarci è che non c'è nulla di
inevitabile Nel scegliere di utilizzare
una tecnologia per risolvere un problema
prettamente umano e sociale perché sono
quelle stesse condizioni sociali e umane
a rendere possibile ogni tecnologia E
quindi noi casomai dobbiamo chiedere a
chi le progetta di assumersi la
responsabilità del loro utilizzo e
riprenderne il controllo di farsi più
domande come quelle che vi ho fatto
prima e soprattutto di non distrarsi
con i rischi
esistenziali piuttosto di pensare agli
impatti
reali a fronte di distopie plausibili
che ci vengono presentate ormai
quotidianamente io Vi propongo di
rispondere e
resistere con delle nuove utopie
possibili
[Applauso]
grazie